Hillary Clinton tries to lead the
resistance Kanye goes to the White House
and we tell the tale of James a student
at the University of California Davis
with a wild wild tale this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
well Howdy Doody we have lots of news to
get to today first a couple
announcements first join me tonight at
my next Yap speech YF speech in Memphis
Tennessee starting at 7 p.m. Eastern I
will be dismantling the left's arguments
one by one
as per my usual arrangement the event is
not live streamed so you're actually
gonna have to show up in person and
don't miss your chance to come and watch
it in person it should be a blast also
if you're watching all of the news about
the midterm elections you know that
great uncertainty is attached to
elections and how those elections go may
mean something for your financial future
well if you are concerned one way to
mitigate downside risk is ensuring that
you are diversified financially and that
means having at least a little bit of
your money in precious metals that's why
I talk to the folks over at Birch gold
Birch gold provides you a hedge against
inflation a hedge against uncertainty
and not only that they're really good at
what they do right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move your eye are eligible 401 K into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
which is perfect for folks who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from future uncertainty like the
uncertainty of the midterms look back
historically when the bottom falls out
gold is a good place to have some of
your money Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau right
now contact Birch gold to request a free
information kit on physical precious
metals ask all your questions and then
once you have at your answers then talk
to my friends at Birch gold about
investing again they'll give you that
free comprehensive 16-page kit showing
how gold and silver can protect your
savings go check them out at
birchgold.com slash been birchgold.com
slash bet well it is important to note
that in the aftermath of the Brett
Kavanaugh saga Republicans have been
gaining ground across the board in the
Senate in the house things still are way
too close to call it is not clear at
this point that Republicans lose the
house although the smart money suggests
that they probably will with that said
all the Senate polls that have come out
since the Brett Kavanaugh saga have been
terrible for Democrats I'm talking about
martha mcsalley in arizona who was down
5 to 7 points in that race suddenly is
up 6 points
to a new poll which is wonderful because
martha mcsalley will be quite a good
senator from the state of arizona in
tennessee the state in which I currently
sit that state has now turned strongly
toward Marsha Blackburn
Phil Bredesen on the heels of a Taylor
Swift endorsement has fallen plummeted
in the polls he is now down to the 30s
according to some polls and Marsha
Blackburn has pulled convincingly into
the lead Claire McCaskill remains
extraordinarily vulnerable in Missouri
so it looks like Republicans could in
fact in this election lose seats in the
House and pick up some significant seats
in the Senate which makes a big
difference because it means that if you
have a four five vote majority in the
Senate next time Republicans have a
judicial pick if Ruth Bader Ginsburg
retires for some reason or if God forbid
something happens to her health-wise
well then Republicans will have the
opportunity to replace her with a strong
conservative a strong textualist most
importantly like Amy Kony Barrett which
would be just unreal and that's a
significant possibility if the elections
go the way they seem to be going right
now now the reason that this shift has
happened is not because of President
Trump it's not because of the
Republicans it is simply because the
Democrats have bared their fangs the
Democrats have decided that they are
going to look as ugly and terrible as
humanly possible in public as often as
possible it's so funny because the
Democrats after after losing to
President Trump decided that what they
really needed to do was be more
off-putting they look at President Trump
and they see that his popularity ratings
hurt in the low forties and I thought
well you know what if we could imitate
that but do it worse right so he won't
have the the kind of blue-collar appeal
of President Trump we won't have these
sort of personal charisma of President
Trump will just be insanely off-putting
and terrible all the time maybe that
will win us power again and it doesn't
seem like it is working the media are
doing their best to try and cover for
this so you have this conflict that is
now happening is gas lighting that is
happening where Democrats are openly
stating openly that they are in favor of
mob politics that they are fine with mob
politics they're fine with people
showing up at restaurants and yelling at
people they are fine with people trying
to beat down the 13-ton bronze doors at
the Supreme Court they are fine with
folks screaming at senators and
elevators they are fine with all of
these things all these things are just
dandy
and then you have folks in the media
saying no no Democrats aren't saying
that there are no mobs that's not that's
not real why would you think
the mob stuff is real and those of us
with the brain are going well because
Democrats said so out loud repeatedly
and then the folks in the media say no
no no no no you're not allowed to listen
to what Democrats say the only mobs that
exist are republican mobs and we say
well name them and they say well
charlottesville say well no that's not a
republican what are you even talking
about in any case let's begin today with
Hillary Rodham Clinton who will not go
away she is like just a bad case of
genital herpes she just will not leave
and she remains on the political scene
really torturing everyone Democrat and
Republican I'm not sure they're that
many Democrats who are extraordinarily
excited about Hillary Clinton still
being around again there's a basic
principle in American politics which is
that after you lose a presidential
election we really don't want to hear
from you pretty much ever again Hillary
Clinton however does not know this rule
so she continues to appear in the media
and say silly things what you have to
love about Hillary Clinton I really mean
that's all you have to love about her is
that she's utterly transparently
mechanical it's like we're moving the
face of a clock you can see all the
gears working in real time so for
example yesterday she was on CNN and
choose asked specifically about civility
now we all know that Hillary is not the
nicest human being and that's that's not
a great shock but Hillary was also the
person who kept saying during the 2016
election every time they go low we go
high when they go low we go high right
now that was her routine during the 2016
election well now she's changed her tune
why is she changed her tune because she
realizes that the passion of the base is
not with civility the passion of the
base is not with decency the passion of
the bases with yelling and screaming and
kicking on the floor like my two and a
half year old son when I tell him he's
not allowed to push em away at school
right that's that's how the Democratic
base is responding to the latest round
of politics she knows that and so
Hillary being transparently manipulative
and political has started to try to
personality mayor now there are certain
people in our office I won't name names
like Michael Knowles who are excellent
at personality mirroring this is just
something that they do it's like a
natural quality if you talk to Michael
Knowles and you are jovial he will be
jovial if you talk to Michael Mol's and
you're in a bad mood he will be in a bad
mood Michael Moses has a unique capacity
to mirror human personality it's one of
the things that makes him roguishly like
is that he mirrors personality quite
well well Hillary Clinton is really bad
at it
Hillary Clinton tries to do it but fail
so she's supposed to be trying to sort
of encompass the rage of her own base
here but it's so mechanical that you can
see all the gears moving and sort of
delightful to see all the gears moving
because you can see once again why she
lost here's Hillary Clinton explaining
that Democrats should not be civil with
Republicans that's the time for civility
is over which makes you wonder when was
the time for civility not over and I was
here for the Obama administration when
the IRS was militarized against
conservative 501c3 groups I was here for
the Obama administration when they were
cramming down a horrific Iran deal that
put our allies in danger and then lying
to the American public about it and then
chortling over lying I was here for the
Obama years when Barack Obama went out
in public and made excuses for rioting
in Ferguson and Baltimore so I'm not
sure what Hillary Clinton is talking
about when she says the era of civility
is over but here is Hillary Clinton
saying we don't need to be civil anymore
because we disagree with Republicans and
why would you be civil with people with
whom you disagree you cannot be civil
with a political party that wants to
destroy what you stand for what you care
about that's why I believe if we are
fortunate enough to win back the house
and/or the Senate that's when civility
can start again so in victory civility
so civility can start again when we
dominate you and put our boot on your
throat that's when civility makes a
comeback now what's funny about this is
that her premise that you can't be civil
to a party that wants to destroy all the
things that you stand for that's the
premise of party politics in the United
States there's not a lot unifying the
Democratic and Republican parties right
now they both want to destroy what the
other party stands for that does not
remove the requirement to be civil now I
think Republicans understand this much
better than Democrats do or at least did
until 2016 the the great untold story of
the last 25 years is that Democrats
categorized every Republican as evil and
nasty and bigoted and homophobic and
racist and all of these terrible things
and finally Republicans responded in
2016 by saying you know what screw you
two we're done and I have a chart to
prove it
so here's a chart from Jonathan heights
new book about polarization in American
politics and here's what it shows
it's partisan hatred before the other
party and you will see that the lighter
line if you're watching this you can see
the lighter line shows that you they
folks who hate the Democratic Party
Republicans who hate the Democratic
Party and the darker line shows
Democrats who hate the Republican Party
what you will see is that until 2016
Democratic hate for the Republican Party
was higher or equal to hate from
Republicans for Democrats every year
since 1980 right that's the actual trend
line here what you see in this trend
line is that since 1980 when Ronald
Reagan won election Democratic hatred
for the Republican Party skyrocketed and
was significantly higher than Republican
hatred for the Democrats all the way up
until 1995 or so then they sort of drew
even and they basically are right on top
of each other and then after george w
bush was elected then democratic hatred
for the republican party skyrocket again
and remained higher this is the part
that's amazing it remained higher than
hatred for the Democratic Party by
Republicans all the way until 2016 which
means even after Barack Obama was
elected Democrats still hated
Republicans more than Republicans hated
Democrats which shows you that
Republicans in the end really believe I
think they believe and I believe this
for decades that Democrats are wrong but
not evil and Democrats believe that
Republicans are both wrong and evil and
in 2016 Republicans finally said listen
you guys think that we're evil well that
makes you evil we're done with this
right you're gonna say that you hate us
just for partisan reasons well we hate
you right back you can go shove it we
are not interested in playing this game
with you anymore that's what's happened
so the media only noticed this around
2016 because the media are partisan
Democrats the folks of the media only
noticed that Republican hatred for
Democrats had skyrocketed in 2016
because for the first time it was
evident that that was the case because
until then Democratic hatred for
Republicans always had exceeded
Republican hatred for Democrats and the
media were part of that problem the
media were forwarding that hatred the
media were cheering it on who was the
media declaring that George W Bush was a
war criminal it was the media declaring
that the Tea Party were a bunch of
terrorists who's the media declaring
that the Tea Party were a bunch of mob
fallacy fans right this was this was
their claim and then in 2016 Republicans
won
partially by saying okay fine we will
activate the hatred within right they'll
fall for the Emperor's trick in Return
of the Jedi well let the hate flow
through us and it would make us powerful
and to a certain extent it did Democrats
thinking that they are going to somehow
win by escalating the amount of hatred
in their hearts again is a pretty
astonishing thing and we're going to
talk about how the media is gaslighting
everybody on this issue in just one
second but first let's talk about those
credit card bills so here is the reality
you've been racking up credit card bills
or maybe it happen and the credit card
at the rates on those credit card bills
are exorbitant if you've been racking up
credit card bills and you are paying
interest rates that are twenty thirty
percent because you have been able to
pay off those bills maybe it's time to
consolidate that debt or pay off your
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment and that's where Lending Club
comes in they've helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans no trips to a bank no high
interest credit cards just go to Lending
Club com tell them about yourself how
much you want to borrow pick the terms
that are right for you and if you're
approved your loan is automatically
deposited into your bank account in as
little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform they have
over thirty five billion dollars in
loans issued go to Lending Club comm
slash pen and check your rate in minutes
you can borrow up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club comm slash been
again Lending Club comm slash been all
loans made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender go check it out right now
Lending Club comm /ban consolidate that
debt put yourself on firmer fiscal
footing Lending Club com / been and let
them know that we sent you with that
slash bet okay so as I say the Democrats
have decided to let the hate flow
through them in order to defeat the
Republicans failing to recognize that it
was Democratic hatred for Republicans
that activated Republicans in the first
place and this is the part that's ironic
the Democrats think by being more
militant maybe more angry that they're
going to get their base riled up and
then they're going to sweep back into
power well they showed how militant and
angry they could be over the last two
weeks and guess what happened in all the
battleground Senate polls they lost
ground because Republicans looked at
that they said oh I remember why I was
scared of you I remember why I was angry
at you and Here I am I'm back and we're
gonna vote this time around well mazie
Hirono is joining the party she along
with Hillary Clinton is now a big fan of
all of this mob sort of stuff I like the
train noise in the background it really
adds an ambient feel to this this whole
show the momentum of a train moving
forward hey case here's mazie Hirono
senator from Hawaii talking about how
there's a mob is that really bad because
I mean the Republicans are all white
supremacist anyway so why not mob them
well this is what happens you know they
because when you look at white
supremacist and all that this is what's
it coming forth in our country there's a
tremendous divisive Ness
in our country but this is the kind of
activism that occurs and people make
their own decisions if they violate the
law then they have to account for that
okay so fun to hear Democratic senators
openly state that they don't really care
about this sort of mob tactic now the
funny part is that the media have
decided the media may be smarter than
the Democrats in all this the Democrats
think they can activate the base and the
media think they can tamp down
Republican response by pretending that
none of this is happening so as the mob
is activated as folks at the Women's
March and folks at the ACLU and folks in
democratic halls of power start saying
that it's okay to railroad a guy without
any due process and then to activate
mobs to go and and storm the the Senate
building and go and storm the Supreme
Court as they sell this the media
maintained over and over that you
shouldn't believe your eyes who can
believe down lemon or your own eyes who
are you gonna believe
who are you going to believe Brooke
Baldwin or your own lying eyes and this
is the way they approach this so last
night on CNN Matt Lewis and Mary
Katharine ham both friends of mine and
both Republicans are on with propelled
win' and they're talking about president
Trump who is labeled democratic politics
mob politics which it is at this point
listen to Brooke Baldwin tried to spin
away I mean it's amazing
listen her try to spin away the fact
that mobs invaded the heart Senate
building and tried to intimidate people
and then once the sand went to the
Supreme Court in tried to beat in the
doors here is here is Brooke Baldwin
Brooke Baldwin doing her best to gasps
like the American people oh it's it's
totally a mob it is without a doubt
there's no other word for us it's a put
up a stop stop but on a mob is what we
saw in Charlottesville Virginia two
August's ago now a mob
it's what we saw chasing I'm gonna tell
you what they did right what about the
people who were at the Supreme Court
banging on the walls what do you call
that civil protest or is that a mob I
think it's easily a mom and there's
Brooke Bob and putting your head in your
hands how could someone call this a mob
why would anyone call it because it's a
mob that's why there's there's an
article in The Washington Post saying
Republicans tried to recast Democratic
protest as mob we'd have to recast
anything and didn't take a lot of work
at all it said something like
Republicans work hard to do it doesn't
take any work at all because all we have
to do is show you the video show you the
pictures it's not just Brooke Baldwin
a lot of the anchors on CNN have
dedicated themselves to the idea that
the only sort of mob that's real is a
mob of white supremacists in Charlotte
so if the only mob we've seen in
politics really we didn't see mobs in
Ferguson we didn't see mobs in Baltimore
we haven't seen mobs in at the Supreme
Court we didn't see mobs at the Senate
building none of this was a mob
occupy what those weren't mobs the only
mobs are right-wing mobs and if you feel
like people are driving you nuts that
they're gaslighting you in line do
that's because they are
take for example Don Lemon so Don Lemon
last night he had on a GOP commentator
named Alice Stewart and she was talking
about President Trump who's ripping on
the Democrats as an angry left-wing mob
and here is how it went down so lemon
said so so Alice Stewart said that
calling these folks a mob was actually
accurate pointing to people who are
banging on the doors of the Supreme
Court and people who harassed senator
Cruz and Heidi Cruz as well as yelling
at Jeff Flake and Susan Collins and
elevators and lemon said but that
doesn't mean people don't get to object
that's her right as an American to
object it's covered in the First
Amendment it's like the first one and
then Louis again chimed in and argued
that anti cabinet protesters engaged in
mild behavior which they did they went
into the actual Cavanaugh Senate hearing
room and they screamed until they were
removed they shouted until they were
moved that's called mob behavior okay so
lemon says no that's not mob behavior
it's people who are upset and they're
angry with the way the country is going
those two things are not mutually
exclusive
mobs typically are angry and upset with
the way a country is going the reason
the media are trying to cover for all
this is because the media are beginning
to realize that shouting at Republicans
is not actually the best strategy for
winning and so they're simply going to
try to convince you
that the person who is shouting in your
ear is not real
it's like Harvey the bunny the giant
bunny it's just imaginary it exists only
in your imagination it's not a real
thing so media doing their best to try
and tamp down the perception of the
public that Trump is actually correct
about all of this and the Republicans
are right when they say it Mitch
McConnell of course is pushing this
forward Mitch McConnell says listen this
behavior and this this Hillary Clinton
comment about civility being out of
balance this is unhinged stuff from the
Democrats and that of course is correct
no peace until they get their way more
of these unhinged tactics apparently
this is the left rallying cry but
fortunately the American people know
that the fact free politics of hate fear
and intimidation are not how we actually
govern in our democratic republic well
this is right I mean the Democrats
acting like pure aisle children is not
going to help them and that's why the
media are trying to convince you that's
not actually what's going on Rand Paul
got himself in a little bit of Twitter
hot water yesterday for comments that he
made that are exactly correct he said
that political assassinations could rise
in the United States somebody could be
killed
thanks to all of this vile rhetoric on
the part of folks like Hillary Clinton
now listen I'm somebody go back and
listen who condemned this sort of
aggressive rhetoric from President Trump
in 2016 in 2016 the presidents of the
United States when he was just a
candidate when he was going to rallies
and saying something like punched
somebody and I'll pay your legal bills
when he was doing that sort of stuff I
said that's bad that's ugly he shouldn't
be doing it well Democrats are the ones
doing it today and it's just as bad it's
just as bad and they're being more
explicit about it too I mean when
Hillary Clinton says civility is not
required with anybody on the other side
of the aisle it's pretty damn explicit
Rand Paul says this sort of stuff is
gonna get somebody killed that doesn't
mean that Hillary Clinton is going to
get somebody killed but the rise in
temperature is likely to reach a boiling
point at some point here Rand says that
he gets all sort of flat all sorts of
flack for it I feel that there's going
to be an assassination I really worry
that someone is going to be killed
and that those who are ratcheting up the
conversation those who Iraq
I'm saying getting their face they have
to realize that they bear some
responsibility of this elevates to
violence now people are saying well what
about Trump
what about Trump okay let's talk about
ran for a second since ran as one who's
making the comment Rand Paul had six of
his ribs broken by a neighbor who
allegedly didn't like his politics and
literally just tackled him on his
property requiring months and months of
recovery Rand Paul also happened to be
one of the people present at the
Congressional baseball game where a
bunch of Congress people were shot at
and Steve Scalise was nearly murdered so
I think that ran actually does have a
certain amount of credibility on this
particular issue well the direction the
country is going is a really ugly
direction and it's got to be stopped one
of the ways to stop that I think is
gratitude now I know I know this is a
word that has gone out of style
gratitude why should we be grateful
clearly things are so bad in America
except things are not bad in America
right now things are very far from bad
in America right now in just a second I
want to explain to you that not only are
things not bad in America things have
not been bad in America for a few
decades here and all of the political
motivation to try and drive us to anger
and panic is completely overstated but
first let's talk about your impending
doom since we're in a dark mood let's
talk about your impending death you're
gonna die you're gonna plotz
and let's just face that reality now
prepare for that eventualities I going
and getting some life insurance you want
to make sure that your family is taken
care of in case god forbid something
happens to you and that's where policy
genius comes in they compare quotes from
the top life insurance companies to find
the best policy for you it takes just
two minutes to get a quote and if you
don't know anything about insurance
they've got all the tools to get you up
to speed you can learn the difference
between term and whole life insurance
calculate how much coverage you need and
be sure you're making the right decision
over four million people have used
policy genius to shop for insurance and
they don't just do life insurance they
do disability insurance and home
insurance and auto insurance if you care
about it they can cover it so whether
you know a lot about life insurance or
nothing at all start your search at
policy genius com in just two minutes
you can compare quotes and make an
informed decision for you and your loved
ones policy genius is the best way to
shop for life insurance go check it out
it's the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance online policy genius.com
again if you are waiting to get life
insurance there's no reason to do so
because who knows what's gonna happen to
you tomorrow that's not a threat that's
a possibility
so go
no policy genius.com I mentioned it's
not a threats I got a threat actually on
Twitter today actually on Twitter was in
the email from a guy who said that he
wanted to behead me which was which was
kind of a unique email I wrote on
Twitter good morning to you too sir but
yeah that's when people say they're
afraid of the way politics is going yeah
I don't think that that is completely
out of bounds with that said the the
solution to that is to be kind of
grateful for the country in which you
live it's hard to be angry at somebody
when when you're also being grateful and
we should be grateful one of the great
wise that's been perpetrated by both
sides of the political aisle for
political purposes over the last several
years has been this lie that nothing in
the United States has gotten better
since 1979 and very often folks
particularly on the Left these days like
to suggest that wage stagnation has
taken place since 1979 and the American
people are worse off for the
globalization liberalisation
liberalizing trade rules lower taxes
that these sorts of things the these
sorts of things have killed the American
economy that if we had just remained a
high tariff nation with less free trade
then we would all be living better but
wage stagnation has led to tremendous
suffering in the United States there's
only one problem I'd like to ask you you
listening right now do you think that
your lifestyle would have been better in
1979 really these two things don't match
up folks who say that 1979 was so
awesome the wage stagnation started then
and then it and then wages have declined
ever since or they've at least remain
static ever since for most people yes
but you are living a better lifestyle on
those same wages so what could explain
this conundrum well I think this is the
most important article of the day it's
by a woman in Mary Ann l2p at human
progress org and here is what she says
she says according to a 2015 report by
the Economic Policy Institute which is a
left wing think-tank based in DC ever
since 1979 the vast majority of American
workers have seen their hourly wages
stagnate or decline this is despite real
GDP growth of a hundred and forty nine
percent and net productivity growth of
64% over this period in short the
potential has existed for ample
broad-based wage growth over the last
three-and-a-half decades but these
economic gains have largely bypassed the
vast majority now it is certainly true
that average hourly earnings of
production and non-supervisory employ
in the private sector have barely
changed between 1979 and 2015 in October
1979 average hourly earnings stood at
651 or 2120 in 2015 dollars if you
adjust for inflation in 2015 average
hourly earnings stood at about 21 bucks
and 18 cents which is slightly below the
inflation adjusted 1979 level but we are
forgetting three important factors and
this is the reason that you are living
better today it's the reason you have
better stuff it's the reason you have a
bigger house it's the reason why your
lifestyle is significantly better than
it was in 1979 one expansion of non-wage
benefits people get all sorts of
benefits that are not wage related in
today's economy second a massive fall in
the price of consumer goods if you are
making the same amounts of money that
you made last year but all the goods are
half as expensive you can buy more of
the goods then it seems pretty intuitive
if you can buy more stuff why do you
care what the number is on your wage
what matters is whether you can trade
that wage for more things and there's
also been a rise in the price of
services like education and health care
those three factors combine to suggest
that the problems in our economy have to
do with government regulation not
deregulation education and health Nara
heavily regulated and to suggest that
trade has been quite good for an
enormous number of Americans even if it
feels like it has not been so here's
what this article suggested human
progress and this is right
in recent decades non-wage benefits
expanded today they include relocation
assistance medical and prescription
coverage vision and dental coverage
health and dependent care flexible
spending accounts retirement benefit
plans group term life and long term
insurance plans legal and adoption
assistance plans child care and
transportation benefits vacations sick
paid time off it's not easy
rights this author Mary Ann topi it's
not easy to put an exact figure on the
value of those non-wage benefits but
they could amount to as much as 30 or
even 40 percent of the workers earnings
so while hourly wage benefits may have
stagnated while hourly wages may have
stagnated benefits certainly have not
the lion's share of non-wage benefits as
Cato's peter van horne wrote in 2011 is
consumed by the dramatic increase in
health insurance costs
he says the fixed cost of health
insurance are a much larger percentage
of the total compensation of lower
earnings workers meaning that you did
get a raise it just came out in your
health insurance
also many perhaps most big-ticket items
used by a typical American family on a
daily basis have decreased in price so
they looked at the at human progress
they looked at the prices of common
household items is advertised in the
1979 Sears catalog and prices of those
common household items sold by Walmart
in 2015 and remember those products in
2015 are a hell of a lot better than the
products in 1979 a washing machine made
in 2015 is a better quality washing
machine than a washing machine made in
1979 a car made today is a better car
than a car made in 1979 all the products
are getting are better and you're
getting them for cheaper here's what
they did they divided the 1979 nominal
prices by 1979 average nominal hourly
wages and 2015 nominal prices by 2015
average nominal hourly wages and they
calculated the time cost of household
items in each year that's the number of
hours it would take to buy a washing
machine for example so for example the
time cost of a 13 cubic foot
refrigerator fell by 52 percent in terms
of the hours of work required at the
average hourly nominal wage so if you
could buy two refrigerators for the
price of one that makes you richer
regardless of what your top-line income
is needless to say the above price
reductions greatly underestimate the
totality of welfare gains by the average
American ignoring qualitative aesthetic
and environmental improvement son
commonly used items again those products
are better today than they were
yesterday
so it's pretty clear it is pretty clear
that when it comes to products that we
can buy we are much better off than they
were in the 1970s so where are we short
we're short in education health care and
housing because the cost of those things
has risen at a faster pace than total
compensation however it is true that
today's houses are larger and healthcare
is better and education is more
high-tech it is also true that the
reason that house that houses have risen
in price is because of tremendous
regulation on the part of Democratic
administrations for the most part in
major cities the reason that you see
housing shortages in Los Angeles which
is the most sprawling city and now in in
the country means where I live is
because of heavy regulation and zoning
so what is the standard of living well
it's certainly it's certainly better
than it was in 1979 for the vast
majority of people in the American
public the average apartment is bigger
the average stuff you have in your
apartment is big
the average house is better the average
stuff that you have in that house is
better all of that should suggest that
maybe we should be kind of grateful for
the country in which we live and stop
trying to tear it down and stop trying
to tear each other apart in the name of
some utopian vision and Democrats might
be wise to start there especially
because the more enraged Democrats get
Republicans lag behind because we are
not fond of the rage but if you enrage
us when you awake that sleeping giant
it's not good for you electoral it is
not good for you okay well in just a
second I want to talk about the
Democrats failure to recognize that
basic truth and what they are saying now
about justice Cavanaugh
but first let's talk about your coffee
if you've ever found yourself wincing at
the weak taste of coffee from a
left-leaning corporate brand that
worries about whether people can use
their bathroom for free as opposed to
buying a cup of coffee well you may have
thought I wish they spent less time on
meaningless biased training and more
time on making coffee that is good and
that's why you need black rifle coffee
black rifle coffee the quality of the
coffee is excellent not only that the
folks who stand behind black rifle
coffee are awesome they're Pro veteran
there are veterans many of them
themselves it is founded by former
special operation vets and black rifle
delivers the best roasts to order coffee
now directly to your door this
guarantees you're getting fresh premium
coffee with every order these are folks
who are not politically correct just
themselves and their coffee tastes like
it would come from folks who are not
politically correct meaning it is strong
coffee it is not watered down in
addition to great coffee and gear black
rifle has a coffee club that makes
things really easy no lines no running
out just great coffee shipped right to
your door every month hassle free plus
when you join that Coffee Club you'll
receive discounts and offers not
available to other customers also they
give a portion of their sales to veteran
and first responder causes so you're
doing something good every time you buy
a cup of coffee from a black rifle visit
black rifle coffee calm slash pen we see
15% off your order that's black rifle
coffee calm / pen for 15% off black
rifle coffee calm / man okay so speaking
of the democratic lack of gratitude for
the country in which they live which is
driving a lot of anger on talk in a
second about a song that has now gone
viral on Twitter and Facebook we'll talk
about it in just one second first you're
gonna have to go over to daily wire and
subscribe when you do you get the rest
of my show live the rest of Andrew
Klavan still alive the rest of michael
moles
terrible show live you get all of those
things plus for $99 you also get the
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr now I
brought it along with me on the trip and
then promptly forgot it in the hotel but
that's only because I wish to protect it
it is that precious to me I didn't want
to bring it outside I have to keep it in
an actual and an actual shrine I like
candles next to it each and every day
that's how good this tumbler is and you
will enjoy it as well plus when you
subscribe you also get access to the
second season of another Kingdom which
comes along with all these great visual
treats you don't get those if you are
not a subscriber we have all sorts of
good stuff that's happening behind the
paywall over at daily wire.com go check
it out plus if you subscribe over at
YouTube or iTunes and leave us a review
which I hope you will do a five star
review that's the only type we accept
you'll also get access to our Sunday
special this week Sundays special
features business leadership guru and
former Navy SEAL jackal willing who
stopped by how's it going on jakka
willing and i am going to be on the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special this coming
Sunday where Ben and I talked about a
wide variety of subjects from parenting
to politics to leadership and just about
everything in between come and check it
out we'll see you then so it's a lot of
fun you're gonna want to see it go check
that out by subscribing at youtube or
itunes again leave us a review a
five-star review if you so choose and
that will ensure that we continue to be
ranked highly at itunes it does help
with the rankings over there okay so we
will see you in just a second on the
other side of this this Facebook break
where the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so let's talk about the fact that
the left doesn't seem to realize they
live in a great country and that they
believe that we all ought to be living
in fear every single day now
fear-mongering is never a wonderful
thing if you're going to get exorcised
about problems in your life you probably
should be exorcised about problems that
are truly prevalent you know things that
are actually a threat to you and
suggesting that every woman in the
country is at risk of rape every second
of every day is probably not a good way
to bring people together it's also not a
good way to view your neighbors because
the truth is that women are not at risk
of sexual assault every day in the
United States America is a pretty safe
country for women in fact it's the free
a safest country for women in the
history of mankind so there's that but
there's a song that's now become very
popular on Twitter and Facebook I'm not
sure what her name is Mercedes Lynne's I
guess and she has put up this song and
folks on the Left are just ecstatic
about this song because it suggests that
men should not be concerned about false
allegations of sexual assault we should
not be concerned about it anymore so you
know men who are worried that in the
aftermath of the Brett Kavanaugh
nonsense that anybody can be accused at
any time without any corroborating
evidence this should sit down and shop
because women have it tough now there's
a logical flaw at the root of this which
is two things can be true once women can
be afraid of bad men and men can be
afraid of bad women why these two things
are supposedly mutually exclusive is
beyond me
I do not understand why saying that
women have a right to be afraid when a
man accost them and treats them terribly
why is that mutually exclusive with a
man has a right to be afraid that a
woman will make a false allegation
against him I'm not saying that the
fears ought to be equivalent in nature
I'm not saying that the level of fear
should be equivalent or that the level
of prevalence of these events is
equivalent but to say that I shouldn't
be afraid of something bad happening to
me because something bad could happen to
you makes no sense at all just on a
logical level and the reason I say this
is because there are cases many cases
across the United States particularly on
campus right now where men are being
accused of things that they did not do
and it's costing them time money and
credibility so here's the story of James
I me sort of James then we're gonna get
into this lady's song so James was a
freshman at the University of
california-davis this is according to
Reason magazine he was on his way to
math class when he received an email
that would derail his life for the next
few months the university's
title mine office which handles sexual
misconduct disputes between students was
investigating a complaint against him
this was in February 2018 right after
Harvey Weinstein and Al Franken and all
the rest James said this was not a good
time to get accused of something like
this the email from the title nine
compliance officer went into great
detail about the seriousness of James
situation he would be investigated in
accordance with University sexual
assault and sexual violence policies as
well as the Student Code which covers
physical assault threats of violence and
conduct that threatens health and safety
a finding of responsibility could result
in suspension or even expulsion but the
email was short on details of the
alleged conduct according to the title
nine office a female student in Becky
had complained it that James touched her
on the breasts and buttocks over and
under her clothing without her consent
James knew Becky they've been classmates
in drama and briefly friends on the
evening of October 20th 2017 they'd met
up with some other friends to play music
eventually finding themselves alone in
Becky's dorm they kissed for a few
minutes and engaged in some light sexual
touching before other students
interrupted them in James's view the
encounter had not only been fully
consensual it was also mutual Becky
bored just as much responsibility for
initiating it as James as Becky would
later make clear to the investigator
she'd also touched him sexually
she explicitly describes her own actions
in her official statement James's
attorney wrote about the incident and
and here's what they wrote
Becky's account of the incident as set
forth in the summary of her
investigative interviews does not on its
face allege any act of prohibited
conduct doesn't matter the investigation
continued until May 1st at which time
the office of student and judiciary
affairs finally concluded that James was
innocent even so Becky was afforded the
opportunity to appeal the decision
consistent with University policy is
dictated by the Obama administration's
Education Department it cost James
twelve thousand dollars in legal fees to
defend himself against an allegation in
which the girl admitted admitted that
she was mutually involved in the sexual
conduct I mean it's pretty astonishing
according to Becky's complaint the
kissing followed a night of mutual
flirting and started out romantic
eventually she either asked James to
close the door closed it herself
they continued kissing and also touching
as they grinded against each other and
he said he says my hands started making
my way up
back slowly respectfully testing the
waters James opened his eyes to make
sure Becky was enjoying what was
happening she seemed into it and so he
touched her over her clothes
James removed his shirt and she told him
to drop it on the floor so in other
words she was involved in every step of
all of this right at one point James
became too forceful he was grinding
against her shoes pressed against a
closet door and Becky asked him to be
more gentle he agreed and toned down the
grinding Becky had missed that she
kissed James's neck but didn't think she
gave him a hickey she did however ask
him whether he was into certain types of
sexual activity and she says that she
was aroused by all of this so she says
all of this to the title nine Court it
cost him twelve thousand dollars anyway
so should men be worried about this sort
of thing why not why wouldn't they be
wouldn't you be worried about the sort
of stuff but according to feminists
because women have a completely separate
set of fears some of which are justified
and some of which are overstated men
should not be worried about anything so
Brett Kavanaugh is guilty because bad
things happen to women is basically the
logic of the left and then they wonder
why folks on the center and on the right
are not interested in this particular
point of view well here is this this
song from Mercedes lens expressing this
bizarre point of view that that women
are threatened bad things happen to them
therefore men should shut up here she is
singing about it this has having five
million views on Twitter it's gone viral
of course
[Music]
they pause it for a second so she can do
all those things all the things you just
said she can't do she can do right the
question is whether they are wise things
to do in particular areas at night so
when I am walking in an area that I feel
is unsafe I don't walk alone in an area
I feels unsafe with my phone in my head
in fact the police tell you you're
probably not supposed to do that if you
don't want to become a target of crime
generally that you probably shouldn't do
that are women more vulnerable than men
of course they are of course they are
but if this means that Brett Kavanaugh
is guilty I'm sort of missing that also
I don't know where she lives but why
can't she sleep with the window open
like I I really don't know where she
lives like maybe she lives in a heavily
crime-ridden area in which case you
might want to get out of there but the
number of break-in entries where people
just kind of like enter your home
randomly because you can't sleep with
the window open it doesn't happen all
that often I don't know about
chaperoning at bars is this a thing like
I haven't heard it frankly of a
chaperone for anything since like the
1920s with dating hey this idea that you
have has she been to a bar like there
are lots of women there with without
chaperones a lot two men there two
without chaperones in fact bars are not
famous for their chaperoning it's not
it's not a square dance you know in the
Hills like what what okay and then when
she says and then when she continues by
saying that she can't wear a miniskirt
even if it's the only one she owns she
literally can do that she literally can
do that in fact she can wear a miniskirt
even if it's not the only one that she
owns women wear miniskirts a lot in our
society
I mean honestly like this this is just
it's not accurate and if she feels fear
about this sort of stuff then I'm not
going to say that her fears are
completely unjustified on every score
but again I don't know why that is a
justification for saying that all women
have to be believed about every
allegation without corroborating
evidence I agree that men can be pigs
and that women are a greater risk of
being targeted by men and men are but
what does that have to do with the price
of tea in China it really has nothing to
do with the main topic at issue but
according to left something bad happened
to me or could happen to me therefore
you should shut up about the possibility
of something bad happening to you which
is just a line of logic I do not
understand in the slightest okay
meanwhile in other news Brett Kavanaugh
is still being run to the ground by
folks on the Left who refused to
acknowledge that he is in fact a
legitimately
pointed Supreme Court Justice of the
United States the Democratic Party is
now selling t-shirts that say on them
supreme injustice which I mean listen we
sell t-shirts here at the Daily wire
like we have a set of t-shirts they say
things like facts don't care about your
feelings which feels like something
you'd want to advertise and feels like a
relatively eternal message I'm not sure
why you would buy a shirt that says
supreme injustice and then just be
wearing it around like in two years is
anyone gonna know what in the world that
t-shirt means the answer of course is no
but this is the take of the Democrats
they cannot let this go and if we don't
let this go we will win yeah that's how
what the polls are showing folks
Jennifer Weiner write to the New York
Times this this sort of come drives me
up a wall how do I explain justice
Kavanagh to my daughters well here's
what you say justice Cavanaugh was
accused of sexual assault back when he
was 17 years old there was no
corroborating evidence to support the
allegation and we don't ruin anybody's
life in this country based on just
allegations without any corroborating
evidence boom did it in two sentences
Wow amazing just amazing I mean that was
just an incredible display of
intellectual dexterity just unreal hey
just amazing amazing but here's what she
actually writes before Hansard politics
President Trump was a fan of different
sort of spectacle professional wrestling
in pro wrestling with its long-running
soap opera like storylines about heroes
and villains faces and heels you don't
win you flatten your opponents you climb
onto the turnbuckle hop onto the ropes
hurl yourself onto the body of your
defeated foe and are declared the winner
that was what Monday night's primetime
swearing-in ceremony of Brett cabinets
at the Supreme Court felt like well
except for the fact that he will
actually sit on the Supreme Court and
then decide cases it's just like WWE and
then here's what she says with his wife
and young daughters in the audience
justice Cavanaugh made all the corrects
conciliatory noises going on was the
red-faced furious man of late September
with his claims about dark money and
Clinton funded plots gone was the man
who alternatively wept and roared and
looked as if he was trying to pass a
kidney stone of compressed rage you
accused him of gang rape you accused him
of gang rape and if he had been robotic
you would have accused him of being
robotic how do I know cuz you did two
days before when he was on martha
maccallum show and then say and then
here's what it says says the gloating
pressed it over the weekend on Saturday
once justice Cavanaugh is a sure thing
Senator John Cornyn tweeted out his
beers for Brett hashtag along with a
picture of a glass of champagne the
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
thanked the clowns who protested justice
Cavanaugh's ascension and helped unify
his party many but he says but this
woman says for the record the clowns the
angry mob the violent protestors were
the women who confronted elected
officials in office halls and in
elevators many are survivors of sexual
violence the same kind that Christine
Blasi for testified she endured they
were trying to get the men in power to
hear them and act accordingly but as I
said that has nothing to do with
anything I may believe your story of
sexual assault that does not mean that I
have to believe every story of sexual
assault but here's the be meat of the
piece what am I supposed to tell my
daughters about all of this of course I
already know I've been talking them
about it for years
be aware of your surroundings okay make
sure someone knows where you are and
when to expect you back don't drink too
much don't put your drink down
don't walk or run or bike the same route
don't stay out too late don't walk alone
in the dark if a guy asks you out and
you're not interested don't hurt his
feelings and don't laugh at him because
a humiliated man is an angry man and
sometimes angry men hurt women and so
some of that I think is good advice just
for anyone like walking alone in the
dark in a crime-ridden area is dumb not
drinking too much make sense right don't
drink too much
that's stupid I've never heard this
thing that if a guy asks you out that
you have to not hurt his feelings like
that that's a new one I haven't heard
that one because frankly I can't think
of a dude that I know who hasn't asked a
woman out and had his feelings hurt I
can't think of a single dude that this
is that this is not happen to and 99% of
dudes don't go on to rape people and
that's that's not actually a thing but
here's what she says she says our girls
will learn to police their clothes their
words their drinking their behavior
their choices because they've been
watching what they've seen is this if
you get hurt it's probably your fault
not a single person says that and if you
tell probably no one will believe you
not a single person says that and even
if people do probably nothing will
happen
not a single person says that either the
conflation of
I'm upset about justice Kavanagh with
America is systemically unjust against
women is just it's it's absurd and it's
a lie and I'm speaking as a guy with my
own daughter and with three younger
sisters it's it's silliness but again
the motivating factor
for a lot of left right now is rage and
they don't understand the debt rage
there's gonna be a delayed effect but
the rage will blow back on them anger is
a short-term high and it's a long-term
low my friend Andrew Clemons is a danger
anger is the devil's cocaine that's
probably about right
you gotta get a very high high and then
you die of an OD and that's basically
what we were what we are risk of right
now okay time for a couple of things
that I like and then we'll do a couple
of things that I hate so things that I
like in this video from a guy named
Justin Norman is just hysterical so he
decided that he was going to create a
new service it's called Nazi maker calm
it's a service so that folks on the Left
can make anyone into a Nazi here's the
here's the video he cuts to push his new
product Nazi maker calm are you looking
to resist fascism but can't find a
single Nazi to punch we've all been
there fortunately due to recent
breakthrough advances in Nazi hunting
technology there's a solution
sounds like capitalism okay we all have
to make sacrifices to save America now
put down that rock and point your
MacBook Pro web browser to a WWN aussie
maker calm now just type in the name of
any conservative centrist or even
liberal and with just a few keystrokes
you can easily transform any person with
whom you disagree and to a freshly
minted white supremacist just look at
how easy it is oh my god you are now and
now that you've turned all of these
public figures into Nazis you can assume
everyone who follows them is a Nazi too
[Music]
and since every Nazi deserves a good
punch in the throat I think we all know
what these disgusting fascists are in
for at their next speaking event
thanks Nagi maker.com hey no problem guy
yep that is a pretty good take on
exactly how the left has decided to
polarize the political debate at this
point now for an actual thing that I
like someone that might be able to bring
us together at least a little bit
Netflix has I've only seen the trailer
to the heaven actually brought out the
series yet it just looks spectacular
it's a new series called Medal of Honor
in which they talk about the stories of
folks who have won the Medal of Honor
and it just looks awesome here's a
little bit of the trailer one thing that
you're gonna learn in combat you learn a
lot about love when you're willing to
put yourself in front of that bullet for
your men that's love the Medal of Honor
is the ultimate form of recognition for
courage on the battlefield
anybody who receives it is immediately
hailed as a hero like none other
it has to be witnessed and people have
to write reports about why this person
deserves it they have earned it and they
have earned it the hard way the Medal of
Honor represents usually the worst day
of your lives
it is important that people hear these
stories it's a legacy and it deserves to
be told or the next generations to come
you carry me about ten miles cause my
friendship
I don't really would try to take this
terrific right I mean this this really
looks good and I can't wait to see it
looks like Scott reenactments and and
documentary stories it just looks it
looks terrific terrific so I'm looking
forward to it and I think you might like
it as well which is why I bring it up
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate so thing I hate number one so
Hillary Clinton everything that she says
is just terrible these days well my
favorite part of this interview she did
on CNN is where she was asked about the
allegations against Bill Clinton based
on her speeches and and her statements
about Brett Kavanaugh and here is what
she had to say about Bill Clinton Brett
Kavanaugh there's a very significant
difference and that is the intense
long-lasting partisan investigation that
was conducted in the 90s if
you know the Republicans starting with
President Trump on down want a
comparison they should welcome such an
investigation themselves okay so I love
this I love this she says they should
welcome an investigation themselves she
literally called it a vast right-wing
conspiracy when people suggested that
her husband was lying about his sexual
activity in the White House but she says
the Republicans should welcome the
investigation also I love that she says
that there's a difference between Bill
Clinton and Brett Kavanaugh right there
was evidence against Bill Clinton he
admitted a lot of the stuff that people
alleged him there was corroborate of
evidence for Juanita Broderick she
talked to people at the time there was
physical evidence that she'd been abused
so yes it turns out that there is a
difference between Brett Kavanaugh and
Bill Clinton Bill Clinton's guilty of
stuff and we have no evidence that Brett
Kavanaugh actually was outside of the
allegations themselves other things that
I hate so the media have done just an
awful job this week like many weeks and
Don Lemon led the pack as soon as we
were done with the Brett Kavanaugh
hearings he went back to the news that's
at the top of everybody's mind and that
news is of course that storm and
Daniel's had sex with President Trump 12
years ago that is at the top every sign
so stormy Daniels has a new book out no
one cares about the book except for her
description of mushrooms apparently but
here was Don Lemon interviewing stormy
Daniels about president Trump's genitals
again and the reason this is not
relevant well because no one accused
President Trump of actual sexual abuse
in this case this was literally a
consensual affair that he had with a
woman 12 years ago but we're still
talking about it I'm getting rather
irritated with all this as amusing as I
find all the Mario Kart references you
said you don't have many regrets but the
one that you have recently is writing
about the president's private parts why
do you regret that um I don't really
regret it I just have a couple of
moments where I'm like oh that was kind
of mean but then I look back and all the
horrible things he said to about other
people and women and calling women pegs
and like you know attacking girls
weights and their looks and then I don't
feel so bad why is she still a thing why
are we still talking about stormy
Daniels at this point I mean barring
some new information about the payoff to
stormy Daniels violating election law
I'm not sure why she's being interviewed
we know her story and her story is
pretty non shocking what did anyone
really think that present
Trump has a long history of stooping
everything on two legs that that guy did
not stop storming Daniels or that there
weren't gonna be descriptions of his
genitals out there but the media is
fascinated by this because of course the
members of the media really really
really hate President Trump
okay well we will be back here tomorrow
don't forget if you are in the Memphis
area I'm speaking at University of
Memphis tonight this one is not being
live-streamed so the only way to see it
is if you actually show up and check
them out I believe that you can see if
there are any tickets available it may
be sold out but I think there probably
some standby tickets in case folks don't
show up go check it out right now
we will see you back here tomorrow I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go visit Graceland
now I'll catch you guys later
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing